.
SHE RECEIVED THE SAME SENTENCE
LAST MONTH.
STAY ONE PRESIDENT BIDEN NOW
RAMPING UP EFFORTS TO GET
AMERICANS VACCINATED AGAINST
COVID.
HE IS LAUNCHING AN EFFORT TO GO
DOOR-TO-DOOR TO GET SHOTS AND
ARMS AFTER FALLING SHORT OF THE
70% GOAL BY THE FOURTH OF JULY.
THE NEW PUSH TO LITERALLY KNOCK
ON DOORS A SPIKING BACKLASH.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR, MOLLY
HERE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THE
DOOR-TO-DOOR CAMPAIGN?
WILL THAT WORK?
>> I AM NOT SURE AT SUCH A
PROGRAM ACTUALLY EXISTS OR IF HE
WAS CONFUSED.
IT'S A PROBLEM WITH VACCINE
ACCEPTANCE IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
FEARFUL OF THE GOVERNMENT WHERE
THEY DON'T TRUST THE GOVERNMENT,
GOING DOOR TO DOOR BY GOVERNMENT
AGENTS IS NOT THE WAY TO HANDLE
IT.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, VACCINATION
RATES IN THE AMONG THE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS, OLDER
PEOPLE, AND PEOPLE WITH
COMORBIDITIES, IS REALLY HIGH.
HE NEEDS TO TAKE THE WIN.
I KNOW HE MISSED HIS PERSONAL
GOAL, BUT WE HAVE DONE A
GOOD JOB, AND HE SHOULD ACCEPT
THAT AND KEEP GOING FORWARD.
>> Bill: WE WILL PROBABLY GET
THERE PRETTY SOON, ACTUALLY.
AND THEN MEANTIME, KEYSTONE, NO,
OPEC, YES.
GAS PRICES ARE UP, RIGHT?
SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS, AND WE
HAVEN'T SEEN IN THIS HIGH.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAYS
THE PRESIDENT WANTS THE CARTEL
TO PUMP OIL THAT THE U.S. TO
PUMP LESS.
AMERICANS PAY MORE FOR ENERGY.
THE WAY OUT OF SUCH
CONTRADICTIONS IS TO LEAD U.S.
CITIZENS RESPOND TO MORE PRICES
WITHOUT NEW POLITICAL OBSTACLES.
HOW DO YOU SEE THIS?
>> THAT IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IF
YOUR GOAL IS TO HAVE ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE OR IF YOUR GOAL WAS
TO HAVE LOW GAS PRICES.
UNFORTUNATELY FOR AMERICANS,
THAT BIDEN ADMINISTRATION BE AS
HIGH GAS PRICES AS A FEATURE,
NOT A BUG.
THAT IS WHY THEY SHUTS DOWN THE
PIPELINE AND WHY THEY WANTED
ISSUE PERMITS FOR PRODUCING OIL
ON AMERICAN LAND.
THEY ACTUALLY WANTED TO LOWER
THE PRICES, THEY WOULD HAVE NOT
TAKEN THE ACTIONS THAT THEY DID
SO FAR.
THEY WANT PEOPLE CONSUMING LESS
OF THE ENERGY, AND THEY DON'T
MIND THE RELIANCE ON FOREIGN
ACTORS.
AND ACTUALLY FITS INTO POLICY AS
WELL.
STAY ONE NIGHT IT IS CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THE DECISIONS THAT ONE COUNTRY
MAKES CAN HAVE AN IMPACT ON
ANOTHER HALF A WORLD AWAY.
JEN PSAKI WAS ASKED EARLIER
ABOUT IT.
SHE SAID THIS.
>> Secretary Psaki: WE HAVE
HAD A TEAM OF OUR OFFICIALS.
WE ARE NOT PART OF THE OPEC
NEGOTIATIONS.
THEY WILL HAVE A BIG FACTOR ON
THE PRICE OF OIL, WHICH HAS A
FACTOR ON OUR GAS PRICES.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
DOING EVERYTHING WE CAN TO GET
THE PRICE OF GAS FLOW.
>> Bill: LEE SHOWED YOU THE
NUMBERS.
TODAY THE PRICES ARE 3.14.
>> THEY HAVE GONE UP
PRECIPITOUSLY SINCE JANUARY.
THAT IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU
DECREASE AMERICANS APPLY AND
WHEN YOU HAVE AN APPROACH TO
ECONOMIC REGULATION THAT
INCREASES COSTS ON PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT A SURPRISE.
THIS IS WHAT THEY HAVE MOVED
TOWARD.
ACTIONS HAVE CONSEQUENCES, AND
THE ADMINISTRATION IT SEEMS TO
WANT SOME OF THE BENEFITS THAT
CAN NBA TROMP ADMINISTRATION
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE MEETING
AWAY FROM THE POLICIES THE
POLICIES.
>> Bill: HOW DO YOU SEE THE
IRONY HERE?
IT'S SOMETHING ELSE, RIGHT?
>> AGAIN, THEY WANT ENERGY
PRICES HIGH.
IT DOES FIT INTO SOME OF THE
CLIMATE CHANGE IS.
THEY THINK OF IT IS HEART DONNA
CARTER FOR BEETLE DEVELOP THEIR
TANKS, IT WILL HELP WITH SOME OF
THEIR GOALS.
IT IS HARD FOR AVERAGE AMERICANS
TO AFFORD.
>> Bill: LET'S K